PROFESSOR: So whenever you
define a recursive data type,
implicit in the
definition is a method
for proving things about it
called structural induction.
And the way structural
induction works
is that if you want to
prove that every element
in some recursively defined data
type has a particular property
P, then you proceed by showing
that every one of the elements
in the base case that
are in R has property P,
and moreover that if you apply
a constructor to an element x,
then it has property P whenever
x has property P. That is,
you can assume as a structural
induction hypothesis P of x
and then you need to show
that P of c of x holds.
And this applies for
each constructor c.
Some constructors take
more than one argument,
but this is meant to
illustrate the general pattern.
Let's do an easy example first.
This is what we've
actually seen.
And we took for granted
this method of proof
without highlighting
it when we argued
that the set E that
was recursively
defined in the last presentation
contained only even numbers.
So remember the definition
of E was that the 0 is in E.
And we're going to be proving
that x is even by induction.
So we need to check the
base case, yes, 0 is even.
And then we need to
show that assuming
the structural induction
hypothesis that n is even,
then when we apply the
constructor n plus 2,
it's even-- well,
obviously it is--
or if we apply the constructor
minus n, that's also even.
And it is as well.
And that's why structural
induction tells us
that in fact, every string
in the set E is even.
Now let's look at a somewhat
more interesting example,
which was the set M of matching
right and left brackets.
And what I want to prove
by structural induction
is that every string in
M has the same number
of left brackets
and right brackets.
I can restate this
by defining EQ
to be the set of strings
with the same number
of right and left brackets.
And what I'm really
trying to say
is that M is a subset of EQ.
All right.
Now the way I'm
going to prove this
is by defining my
induction hypothesis P of s
to be that s is in EQ, that is
s has an equal number of left
and right brackets.
Well, let's remember what
the definition of M was.
The base case of M was the empty
string with no brackets at all.
And does the empty
string satisfy P of s?
Well, yeah.
It has 0 right brackets
and 0 left brackets
so it does have an equal number
of left and right brackets.
So we've established that the
base case P of the empty string
is true.
Now we have to consider
the constructor case.
In the case of M, there's
only one constructor,
namely if r and t
are in M, then so
is s, which you get by
putting brackets around r
and following it by t.
Well, here's the argument.
We're allowed to
assume-- we're trying
to prove that s has an
equal number of left
and right brackets.
And we're allowed to assume
that r does and so does t.
So let's look at the number
of right brackets in s.
Well, where they come from?
The right brackets in
s consist of-- well,
the first symbol in
s is a left bracket,
so that doesn't matter.
Then it's the right
brackets in r.
And then there is a new right
bracket that gets added.
And then there are the
right brackets in t.
So what I can say is that the
right brackets in s are simply,
the number of them is
the sum of the number
in r plus the
number in t plus one
more, cause the constructor
threw in one more right
bracket.
By exactly the same
reasoning, the number
of left brackets
in s is the number
of left in r, left in t plus 1.
Now, because of
hypothesis P of r,
the number of right and left
brackets in r are equal.
And likewise, by the
induction hypothesis P of t,
the number of right and left
brackets in t are equal.
And so the right hand sides
of both of these equations
are equal.
And that means that the
left hand sides are equal.
We've just proved that the
number of right brackets in s
and the number of left brackets
in s are the same, so P of s
is true.
The constructor case is covered.
And we can conclude by
structural induction
that every s in the set
M, recursively defined
set of strings of matched
brackets, is in fact
has an equal number of left
and right brackets, which
means that M is a
subset of Q as claimed.
Well, those were pretty
easy structural inductions.
And as with regular
induction proofs,
when you get the right
induction hypothesis,
the proofs tend to be easy.
And we are going to work
on an interesting example
having to do with
the F18 functions.
One of the reasons
why the F18s are
what's considered in
first term calculus
is that if you look at all of
those functions-- remember,
you've got them by
taking constant functions
and the identity function
and the function sine x,
then you could combine
them in various ways
by adding, multiplying
exponentiating,
composing, taking
inverses-- that we
didn't need to add a constructor
of taking the derivative.
Because it turns
out that you can
prove by structural
induction that the F18s are
closed under taking derivatives.
And that makes a
lovely class problem.